[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 j'espère que
vous avez passé un bon weekend nous
sommes le lundi 20 mars voici le
programme de ce soir ce soir dans votre
site twitch nous vous proposons une
grande page sur l'emploi et la formation
airway le l'entreprise spécialisée dans
les solutions de climatisation et de
chauffage vient de lancer sa nouvelle
académie à Montigny-le-Bretonneux nous
en parlerons avec le CO du groupe
Laurent Rogel focus également sur le
GRETA des Yvelines qui offre la
possibilité aux adultes de suivre de
nombreuses formations pour prendre un
nouveau départ professionnel les détails
dans cette émission avec Luc nouvelle
conseiller en formation continue pour le
GRETA des Yvelines toujours sur cette
même thématique de l'emploi Versailles a
tenu un salon pour favoriser le
recrutement des personnes de plus de 45
ans en 2021 un seigneur sur deux était
sans emploi en plein débat sur la
réforme des retraites les
quinquagénaires multiplient les
candidatures sans succès les témoignages
à retrouver au micro de notre
journaliste Julien Leroy et puis comme
chaque lundi nous terminerons cette
émission par une page sport focus
notamment sur de la natation avec le
Giant Open qui s'est déroulé hier à
Saint-Germain les nous ferons également
le point sur la 27e guyancourse qui aura
lieu ce week-end et enfin nous parlerons
de l'écotrail Paris qui s'est tenu
samedi dernier l'événement souhaite
réduire son impact sur l'environnement
et je le disais à l'instant ce soir nous
vous proposons une grande page sur la
formation et l'emploi dans les Yvelines
avec nous en plateau pour en parler Luc
nouvelle bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes
conseiller en formation continue pour le
GRETA deselines des Yvelines alors
première question qu'est-ce que le GRETA
des Yvelines en quelques mots et bien le
GRETA des Yvelines c'est d'abord le
premier
formateur national c'est un réseau et
c'est lié à l'éducation nationale en
fait mais c'est la formation continue
pour adultes
dans quelques instants avec nous
également un plateau Laurent Rogel
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes le CEO
du groupe airwell qui est situé à
Montigny le Bretonneux l'entreprise
vient de lancer airwell Academy il
s'agit du second centre de formation en
France dédiée à la filière du génie
climatique tout ce qui touche au
chauffage ou à la climatisation même à
la ventilation pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez décidé d'ouvrir cette école ça se
centre de formation dans les Yvelines
alors à l'origine ok c'est un fabricant
de pompe à chaleur comme vous le disiez
qui s'est transformé il y a quelques
années maintenant pour un fournisseur de
solution globale autour de l'efficacité
énergétique et sans entrer dans les
détails pour faire l'efficacité
énergétique il faut parler d'écosystème
il faut parler de solutions globale il
faut apporter de nouvelles solutions pas
que la technologie pompe à chaleur mais
apporter des offres solaires de la data
de l'intelligence artificielle tout ça
donne une efficacité énergétique et on
s'est rendu compte à force de développer
nos solutions que la filière manquer
cruellement de de connaissance
d'expertise donc on a commencé à
développer un centre de formation sur la
partie certification métier pour aider
nos partenaires installateurs et
distributeurs à se sur sa nouvelle
technologie et puis au fil au fil de
l'eau on s'est surtout rendu compte des
grandes difficultés que nos clients
rencontrés dans les recrutements surtout
sur la partie bassin Bassin parisien et
50 ans en Yvelines nous sommes depuis
maintenant une quarantaine d'années et
donc on a décidé d'aller un peu plus
loin dans la formation qu'on pouvait
proposer à nos clients en offrant un
deuxième lot une formation toujours
certifiante qualifiante mais aussi un
deuxième lot autour de l'insertion sur
des personnes en recherche d'emploi
seniors comme vous le disiez jeune
réfugiés etc qui sont des populations
qui sont souvent un petit peu en dehors
des scopes de Pôle Emploi pour les
accompagner dans dans des métiers
attention et qui sont très rémunérateurs
donc ils pouvaient les intéresser et
donc c'est la RER académie on en parlera
plus en détail également tout à l'heure
ce soir nous sommes aussi avec deux
journalistes de la rédaction de TV 78
mais qu'elle est le midoro bonsoir alors
comme d'habitude le lundi vous nous
présenter les résultats sportifs qui ont
eu lieu ce week-end dans les Yvelines de
quoi est-ce que vous allez nous parler
ce soir alors vous l'avez dit on va
parler de l'écoterelle Paris qui est
parti depuis à l'île de loisirs de 50
ans en ligne pour rejoindre le premier
étage de la Tour Eiffel et les premiers
ont mis environ à votre avis
quasiment 5 heures à 5h30 pour réaliser
du coup 80 km on parlera également
football et de Poissy qui a fait match
nul contre la réserve de Caen parlait
également de la première division de
district et beaucoup d'autres résultats
sportifs dans quelques instants ce sera
en deuxième partie de l'émission restez
bien avec nous Céline Charles vous vous
allez nous présenter les informations à
retenir dans les Yvelines mais avant
jetons un coup d'œil à la météo de
demain
[Musique]
matin pour ce premier jour de printemps
le ciel devrait être dégagé sur la
partie sud-ouest sud-est du département
dans le nord-ouest les nuages se
resteront bien présents au niveau des
températures il fera 9 degrés à Houdan
Rambouillet et Versailles et 10 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'après-midi le
soleil devrait être au rendez-vous sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines avec de belles
éclaircies côté température il fera 14
degrés en moyenne sur l'ensemble du
département et demain ce sera la sainte
Clémence le point maintenant sur les
informations à retenir dans les Yvelines
et donc c'est avec vous Céline Charles
le sixième rapport d'évaluation du GIEC
le Groupe d'experts intergouvernemental
sur l'évolution du climat vient d'être
publié oui Mathilde il vient clore ainsi
que de travaux commençaient en 2015 le
rapport concerne l'épreuve physique du
réchauffement climatique ces impacts et
les mesures qui peuvent être prises pour
le contrer il stipule par exemple que le
climat mondial s'est réchauffé de 1,1
degré depuis la fin du 19e siècle un
réchauffement dû en majorité au gaz à
effet de serre lié à l'activité humaine
le rapport se veut tout de même
encourageant puisque je cite des
solutions d'atténuation et d'adaptation
réalisable efficace et peu coûteuse
existent déjà Jean Jouzel
paléoclimatologue ancien membre du GIEC
et directeur de recherche émérite au CEA
Commissariat à l'énergie atomique à
livrer sa propre lecture du rapport il
porte également un discours d'espoir
pour lui il est encore possible d'agir
si l'action est immédiate
c'est la Semaine nationale de la petite
enfance à cette occasion Céline se tient
un forum sur les métiers dans ce secteur
et c'est le premier forum dédié au
métier de la petite enfance il se
déroulera le jeudi 23 mars de 13h à 18h
à l'Hôtel de Ville de Versailles
découvertes formation et recrutement
sont les maîtres mots de la journée
écoutez
en direction donc d'un public de
demandeurs d'emploi de toute personne
qui serait intéressée par un métier
d'abste enfance que ce soit est en
maternel ou éducatrice de jeunes enfants
ou encore de puériculture ces trois
espaces bien distincts un premier espace
où on va pouvoir effectivement découvrir
les métiers de familiariser un deuxième
espace où on va pouvoir rencontrer des
organismes de formation si on n'est pas
formé si on a besoin d'une formation et
puis un troisième espace on va pouvoir
rencontrer des recruteurs qui sont en
recherche de salariés
il y a la possibilité de s'inscrire le
via Pôle emploi mais aussi de venir
directement sur place près de 200
personnes se sont rassemblées samedi 18
mars devant le siège de l'UNESCO à Paris
c'est mieux oui devant le bâtiment ils
ont brandi des dizaines de baguettes de
pain un symbole qui vise à alerter sur
la menace que fait peser la construction
des lignes 17 Nord et 18 wests du Grand
Paris textes sur les terres céréalières
de Gonesse et de Saclay plus de 3000
hectares pourraient être détruits les
personnes présentes portées par les
collectifs contre la ligne 18 et pour le
Triangle de Gonesse demande le
classement de ses sols au Patrimoine
Mondial de l'Humanité Dimanche dernier
se déroulait dans les Yvelines plusieurs
cérémonies pour commémorer la fin de la
guerre d'Algérie exactement et cette
journée permet chaque année de
commémorer les accords d'Évian du 18
mars 1962 qui signe la fin de la guerre
d'Algérie des cérémonies se sont
déroulées dans plusieurs communes des
Yvelines pour rendre hommage à toutes
les victimes civiles et militaires
tombés durant la guerre à la verrière le
maire Nicolas Dainville était accompagné
de plusieurs membres de la fédération
nationale des anciens combattants en
Algérie et aujourd'hui c'est
officiellement le printemps Céline et ce
sera ce soir à 22h24 et 24 secondes pour
être plus précise il est très précis
voilà alors il est vrai que dans nos
têtes le printemps commence tous les ans
le 21 mars alors pourquoi le 27 année et
depuis 2007 d'ailleurs tout simplement
parce que le printemps ne démarre jamais
véritablement à date fixe il est lié à
l'équinoxe de printemps c'est-à-dire le
moment où le soleil est parfaitement
aligné avec l'équateur la durée du jour
est alors aussi longue que celle de la
nuit c'est à cette heure que l'on
détermine le passage au printemps bien
merci beaucoup Céline charge c'était
très intéressant on en sait plus sur le
passage au printemps et si vous aussi
comme d'habitude vous voyez une
information ou une image qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager en utilisant le hashtag
7 8 news
[Musique]
on ouvre à présent une large page emploi
et formation le GRETA des Yvelines est
un organisme de formation continue
destiné aux adultes ces formations
permettent aux demandeurs d'emploi ou
aux salariés de s'insérer sur le marché
de l'emploi ou de se reconvertir et pour
plonger ou replonger ces personnes dans
le monde de l'entreprise le GRETA des
Yvelines a ouvert en 2016 une entreprise
école appelée également entreprise
d'entraînement pédagogique elle a pour
objectif de simuler le fonctionnement
d'une entreprise dans le secteur
tertiaire fauchek fausse alerte faux
bilan faux clients mais 67% des
bénéficiaires retournent vers l'emploi
grâce à ce dispositif pour en parler
avec nous Luc nouvelle vous êtes
conseillé en formation continue pour le
GRETA des Yvelines alors première
question est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter cette école cette entreprise
école alors effectivement l'école
d'entreprise pédagogique qui est née en
2016 dont je suis aussi le président
voilà puisque c'est une entreprise
virtuelle certes mais qui fonctionne
comme n'importe quel PME ou PMI donc
cette entreprise a pour vocation
effectivement d'être un tremplin qui
doit amener les bénéficiaires vers
l'emploi elle est née en 2016 mais en
fait c'est un concept qui est beaucoup
plus ancien c'est un concept qui vient
les États-Unis mais surtout qui a été
importé en Allemagne en 1980 et le
co-fondateur de cette idée était présent
ce matin monsieur trotton qui a
développé effectivement cette idée que
il était intéressant de mettre les gens
en formation professionnelle mais non
pas forcément de manière théorique mais
d'allier la théorie à une pratique
directe voilà donc a l'EP d'Achères vous
avez des plateaux techniques qu'on
appelle qui sont liés au service de
l'entreprise donc vous avez des
secrétaires vous avez des comptables
vous avez des ressources humaines et
vous avez effectivement aussi du
commerce voilà
personne au total dans cette entreprise
générale il y en a au moins une
quarantaine qui font vivre le pays avec
une direction qui est liée aussi donc il
y a des coordonnatrices pédagogiques et
assistantes qui font vivre au quotidien
et qui mettent en action avec des
formateurs qui sont considérés comme des
chefs de service du coup les personnes
donc c'est des salariés si vous voulez
de l'EP mais qui reproduisent les mêmes
attentes par rapport aux besoins de
l'entreprise et donc
de la réussite de ce dispositif selon
vous et ben la réussite en fait c'est
que les personnes se sentent accompagnés
et il y a une individualisation qui est
faite au quotidien donc ça veut dire
qu'en fait vous n'êtes pas jeté dans des
méandres quand vous êtes en difficulté
quand vous êtes salarié en reconversion
ou quand vous voulez devenir chef
d'entreprise voire demandeur d'emploi
donc vous avez un accompagnement vers la
réussite en fait qui permet avec des
bilans intermédiaires de solutionner en
tout cas d'apporter des plus aux
personnes et donc il y a
[Musique]
vous avez entre 100 et 130 personnes qui
sortent de l'EP et donc tout le monde
peut y accéder ou est-ce qu'il y a des
critères
on peut y accéder vous évidemment un
positionnement lié au projet de la
personne après un sourcing qui peut être
de Pôle emploi ou d'individus qui nous
trouvent sur Internet et vous avez aussi
le handicap qui est mis en avant puisque
effectivement comme on a une convention
avec la Gifi et bien on peut recevoir
des personnes dites handicapées
puisqu'on leur offre la possibilité de
se réinsérer en tout cas de voir sur nos
plateaux techniques qui sont accessibles
et on peut aussi les aider dans tout ce
qui est matériel adéquat avec leurs
problèmes pour pouvoir les intégrer
effectivement
à l'entreprise
comment on fait pour pour accéder à
cette formation est-ce que c'est gratuit
les financements viennent soit de la
région soit de Pôle emploi soit du CPF
soit de la transition pro puisque
actuellement on en parle peu mais c'est
un moment important puisque tout salarié
peut effectivement bouger évoluer et
changer de métier grâce à ce dispositif
donc c'est financé en partie mais est-ce
qu'on doit mettre quand même un peu la
main à la poche alors on règle générale
actuellement non d'accord voilà même
avec la Gifi en fait vous avez des
personnes qui sont prises en charge et
donc vous proposez des formations dans
quel domaine dans quel secteur alors là
principalement à l'inverse du Greta de
manière générale qui propose 9 domaines
d'activité là le P est lié au tertiaire
principalement c'est pour ça que je vous
ai énuméré un petit peu les métiers qui
étaient dispensés voilà par les
formateurs et par le P et donc vous avez
eu la visite
[Musique]
plus de 45 ans voilà le but du salon les
rendez-vous de l'emploi qui s'est tenu
jeudi dernier à Versailles près de 600
profils expérimentés étaient présents
pour espérer décrocher un contrat de
travail l'occasion pour nous de faire le
point sur l'embauche des seniors en
France le reportage de Julien Leroy
assistante juridique pendant près de 20
ans Martin Lama a décidé de se
reconvertir à l'âge de 51 ans elle vient
d'obtenir un titre professionnel
d'assistant de direction mais reçoit
pour le moment peu de réponses à ces
candidatures j'ai un peu l'impression
que
on peut me reprendre pour une débutante
que je ne suis plus du tout
et j'ai l'impression que l'âge c'est un
gros frein 56% c'est le taux d'emploi
des 55 64 ans en 2021 une moyenne
inférieure de 4,5 points par rapport à
l'Union européenne selon le ministère du
Travail face à ce constat la deuxième
édition des Rendez-vous de l'emploi pour
les seniors étaient organisés ce jeudi
16 mars à Versailles objectif de ce
salon favoriser la rencontre entre les
600 profils expérimentés et les 35
employeurs présents vous savez qu'on est
quand même dans une période de tension
sur beaucoup de métiers de difficultés
de recrutement et c'est pour cela qu'on
voit des entreprises qui auparavant ne
recrutaient pas des seniors et de
présentes
préconise aujourd'hui au cadre qui sont
vraiment seniors de pouvoir justement
appuyer sur leur apport et leur
expertise qui peuvent amener aux
entreprises cette société de conseiller
de communication créée il y a 35 ans
emploie une centaine de personnes dont
une cinquantaine à Versailles la
structure va embaucher sur une dizaine
de postes dans les prochains mois vous
avez des entreprises ou l'activité
physique est importante et là
effectivement c'est sans doute plus
difficile de gérer l'emploi des
collaborateurs le plus seniors en ce qui
nous concerne on fait
95% de travail
intellectuel chez les clients ou dans
nos bureaux donc là on n'a pas de
problème de pénibilité selon le
ministère du Travail le taux d'emploi
chez les femmes entre 55 et 64 ans et
plus bas de 3,5 points par rapport aux
hommes elle travaille aussi davantage à
temps partiel
le groupe airwell spécialisé dans les
solutions de climatisation et de
chauffage vient de lancer son deuxième
centre de formation à 50 ans en Yvelines
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux plus
précisément ce dernier est dédié à la
filière du génie climatique donc tout ce
qui traite au chauffage à la
climatisation et à la ventilation au
total 3 formations pour en parler avec
nous Laurent Rogel je le rappelle vous
êtes le CO du groupe airwell alors quels
sont ces trois formations qui sont
proposées par la rwell Academy alors on
est sur des formations alors à l'origine
comme je vous le disais on a créé cette
airway Academy pour répondre aux besoins
de la filière donc on était beaucoup
plus sur des formations métier pour leur
apprendre les rudiments du métier
comment bien installer des pompes à
chaleur parce que 90% des problèmes en
général viennent de problèmes
d'installation donc bien installé suivre
les règles dollars etc après on est
arrivé sur une phase beaucoup plus
certification qualification
pour pour travailler sur nos métiers par
de la même manière l'État a mis en place
à juste titre énormément de
certification de régulation pour
s'assurer que les formateurs et les
bonnes les bonnes compétences donc des
Cali packs des Cali PV on appelle ça des
labels RGE etc
reconnu garant de l'environnement etc
donc toute cette partie certification
était nécessaire et la troisième le
troisième niveau le troisième étage on
va dire c'était pour répondre à ce
besoin de ce besoin de force vive que
nos métiers rencontrent alors pas que
nos métiers mais les nôtres qui
connaissent une très très grosse
croissance on est sur un marché qui
croit de 20 à 30% par an donc ça
nécessitait énormément de main d'oeuvre
et de qualité donc la plupart de nos
acteurs de nos partenaires installateurs
se trouvaient vraiment en difficulté
pour recruter pour recruter les
personnes qualifiées donc on est en
cours de construction et c'est un peu le
but de ce deuxième centre de formation
ici qui va aussi faire les formations
certifiantes et qualifiantes mais qui va
se développer sur la partie insertion
donc qui va travailler avec avec les
organismes de public pour créer des
formations diplômantes permettant de le
GRETA permettant de proposer des des
installateurs alors c'est des formations
qui peuvent les trois mois à 18 mois en
de la qualité ou la pétanque technique
ou de niveau de certification du
stagiaire on adapte la formation
au personnel pour qu'ils puissent au
bout de cette période trouver un emploi
soit chez nous parce qu'on a évidemment
des besoins soit auprès de notre réseau
de nos réseaux d'installateurs et
distributeurs qui eux ont des besoins
significatifs sur la région de
Saint-Quentin mais aussi sur le Bassin
parisien donc vous en avez un peu parlé
mais quel est l'objectif de ces trois
formations c'est permettre une meilleure
insertion vers l'emploi c'est un peu
multiple disons on a lancé une démarche
alors qu'on appelle RSE sur le donner un
nom il y a quelques années autour de la
responsabilité sociale sociétale et
environnementale de l'entreprise on
estime qu'une entreprise a avant tout
une raison sociale pas forcément qu'une
raison financière donc à ce titre on a
développé toute un organisme toute une
organisation avec des indicateurs un peu
différents que simplement gagner de
l'argent sur le développement de notre
bassin territorial de la société autour
de nous et d'apporter cette touche
environnementale aussi donc quand vous
faites l'ensemble de ces la jonctions
avec ces trois ces trois ambitions on va
dire on s'est rapproché aussi de de la
BPI la banque publique d'investissement
donc on est ce qu'on appelle coq vert
donc ça fait c'est la communauté de
toutes les entreprises qui touchent la
transition énergétique et environ 1000
entreprises en France mais donc vous
faites le lien entre la transition
énergétique et l'insertion finalement
parce que c'est extrêmement important
d'apporter cette offre d'insertion sur
des métiers à l'avenir tant qu'à faire
c'est quand même plus simple de former
des personnes et de les insérer sur des
métiers qui vont durer plusieurs
dizaines d'années et qui sont
rémunérateurs donc le l'alignement des
étoiles s'est fait relativement
facilement autour de cette de cette
ambition et donc justement à qui
s'adresse ces formations
des scolarisé au seniors en recherche
d'emploi depuis de nombreuses années au
réfugiés à toutes les personnes sur les
toutes les populations qui ont besoin
d'être insérées qui ne sont pas
forcément dans les parcours habituels
type Pôle emploi parce que cela
finalement
l'État ou les organisations les suivre
relativement bien on est sur un niveau
de quasi pleine emploi même largement
plein d'emploi sur nos métiers donc on
doit chercher on doit sourcer comme on
le disait tout à l'heure on doit sourcer
des personnes qui ne sont pas dans les
radars habituels de ce qu'une entreprise
comme la nôtre a l'habitude ou de ou nos
clients ont l'habitude de trouver donc
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin le
secteur du génie climatique se porte
bien sur le territoire de 50 ans
à peu près tous les jours pour se rendre
compte de l'importance de de la
rénovation énergétique en général du
fait que la pompe à chaleur sous la
seule solution qui soit validée par
l'Europe et donc par la France pour la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments et
que donc les installateurs et les
mainteneurs ont un travail devant eux
considérable le problème de ces
installateurs n'est pas leur carnet de
commandes et de savoir comment ils vont
trouver les employés pour réaliser ce
carnet de commandes donc on est là aussi
en dehors de la en dehors de leur
proposer des solutions innovantes et des
produits on est là aussi pour leur
proposer des solutions de recrutement
avec des personnes qualifiées alors
comment on fait pour s'inscrire à ces
formations alors on a inauguré le centre
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la semaine
dernière donc c'est tout les peintures
sont encore fraîches donc on a un site
un roi L académie.com ou sur le site
airway.com le site général du groupe on
trouve forcément les liens ou sur
internet évidemment
après on rentre dans un parcours
qualifié enfin dire qualifiant on
vérifie quand même l'expertise le
l'historique le comportement de chaque
de chaque de chaque personne parce qu'on
est sur des populations très différentes
très diverses on parle on intègre pas du
tout la main de la même manière une
personne réfugiée qu'un jeune des
scolarisé aucun seniors on est sur des
sur des prérequis on va dire sur le le
comportemental de plus en plus beaucoup
plus important que sur des formations
métier que nous on avait l'habitude de
dispenser donc il y a il y a un peu de
travail en amont qui est réalisé par des
spécialistes chez nous qui ont
l'habitude de ce genre de de population
pas et dès lors qu'on a passé cette
période là après on rentre dans une dans
une période qui s'adapte comme je vous
disais de trois mois à 18 mois en
fonction de la compétence technique ou
du de l'historique
de la personne et bien merci beaucoup
à nos questions si vous êtes intéressé
par les formations dispensées par la
rwell Academy vous trouverez donc plus
d'informations sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran allez
c'est l'heure maintenant d'ouvrir une
page de sport dans votre 7 8
[Musique]
et Mickaël vous êtes toujours là pour
nous parler des résultats sportifs du
week-end dans les Yvelines l'actualité a
été riche ce week-end on commence par
une course la 16e édition de
l'écoterelle Paris s'est tenue ce samedi
18 mars un rendez-vous qui se veut
éco-responsable en limitant son impact
environnemental et qui s'adresse à tous
les profils de coureurs Grégory canalett
était allié de loisirs de 50 ans en
Yvelines au départ du parcours du 81 km
reportage c'est toujours un grand moment
de sport voilà plus qu'une heure avant
le top départ
ultime échauffement dernier briefing
moment de concentration pour les 2600
traits leur présent à l'île de loisirs
de 50 ans en Yvelines il s'apprête à
s'élancer pour le 80 km de l'écotrail
ça va ça va falloir le faire maintenant
qu'on y est comment ça me sentir un
petit peu stressé mais ça va être super
chouette hyper impatiente et hyper
impatient d'arriver à la Tour Eiffel
sûrement de nuit mais ça va être super
magnifique on va partir trop vite je
pense c'est surtout ça va partir trop
vite pour pouvoir accélérer sur la
faille garder du sucre alors que la
pluie était annoncé ce samedi 18 mars le
soleil finalement rendez-vous de la
matinée une sixième édition qui
s'annonce sous de bons hospices voilà on
a plus le choix là là on a tout le monde
est dans les starting là ça fait une
semaine que toute l'équipe d'orgas et à
fond moi ça fait même des mois et des
mois et là on est on est prêt on attend
juste que le départ soit donné avec les
coureurs puissent s'amuser créé en 2008
les cauterelles paris promu une pratique
de la course à pied co-responsable au
menu 5 traits les deux marches nordiques
de quoi satisfaire tous les profils
fidéliser les habitués à tirer de
nouveaux venus c'est un beau challenge
parce que j'ai déjà fait le 2 éditions
de 45 45 km parce qu'en fait c'est une
course éco-responsable au 80% on se
déroule dans les milieux urbain et que
je partage avec mes amis on habite à
côté donc ça passe devant la maison
c'est sympa on connaît le on connaît les
bois par cœur c'est la maison c'est
notre jardin moi j'aime bien remonter à
Paris chaque printemps ici il y a tous
mes potes sur Paris alors c'est vrai que
c'est rare de revenir des Alpes pour les
côtelettes mais bon c'est ça change ça
change de terrain très excité à l'idée
de d'arriver à la Tour Eiffel et de et
de profiter de ce magnifique paysage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à 11h30 le départ du 80 km est donné les
coureurs vont tenter de rejoindre le
premier étage de la Tour Eiffel
pour aller rejoindre derrière Buc la
forêt domaniale de Meudon à Chaville le
domaine de Saint-Cloud et puis après
tout droit jusqu'à la tour Eiffel et
puis les 137 dernières marches pour
franchir la ligne d'arrivée après
seulement 5h42 minutes et 40 secondes
yuan stuck ça juge la 16e édition de
l'écoterelle Paris chez les hommes Katie
Shyde s'impose du côté des femmes en 6
heures 23 minutes les couterraines paris
2023 réunis près de 13000 participants
sur l'ensemble des courses proposées le
rendez-vous est pris pour l'année
prochaine
on continue avec de la course à pied
dans cette partie sport une autre course
se déroulera ce dimanche sur les
territoires de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
il s'agit de la Guyancourt un 10 km au
coeur des étangs de la minière pour en
parler avec nous Damien de France
l'organisateur bonsoir et Sophie
Gatelier bénévole est présidente de
l'association de l'ère bonsoir bonsoir
alors excusez-moi je suis pas présidente
justement de la chambre de l'association
alors on fêtera ce dimanche 27 la 27e
édition qu'est-ce que ça vous fait de
fêter cette 27ème édition de la
Guyancourt
que la guyancourse existe donc c'était
elle est toujours autant populaire et
puis ça nous fait plaisir de faire
découvrir aux gens la nature les étangs
de la lumière donc ce sera un 10 km
pourquoi un 10 km
cette distance on a vu les cotterelles
avec un 80 kilowatts
parce que c'est accessible à tout le
monde même une personne qui court pas
beaucoup peut venir faire la Guyancourt
on est vraiment sur une course sympa on
n'a pas besoin d'être un super athlète
on peut venir courir tranquillement la
Guyancourt et puis faire les 10 km
prendre le temps qu'on veut on n'arrive
pas au premier étage de la Tour Eiffel
mais on arrive sur le gymnase des droits
de l'homme qui est aussi sympathique
puis on a droit un petit cadeau à
l'arrivée pour un comme récompense de
cet efforts qui s'entraîne dur pour ça
que certains qui s'entraînent dur on est
à 36 minutes quand même sur les 10 km
700 exactement avec une petite montée
assez importante au milieu du parcours
donc maintenant il y en a qui
effectivement qui qui court à très vite
vous attendez combien de personnes
environ alors aujourd'hui on est à peu
près à 150 inscriptions au niveau adulte
un petit peu plus au niveau en fond
parce qu'on a trois courses enfant
avant la Guyancourt on va dire mais on
espère que ça va gonfler cette semaine
et qu'on arriverait autour des 200 250
cours et pourquoi pourquoi du coup les
enfants vous les attirés pour aller un
peu plus tard vers les 10 km peut-être
exactement après les enfants c'est
ouvert à n'importe quel enfant bon il
faut un certificat
en cours il y a beaucoup de
représentants de l'école de l'athlétisme
de l'esqui de dont on fait partie mais
voilà c'est ouvert à tous les enfants et
puis on fait pas mal de promotions dans
les écoles de Guyancourt donc voilà
c'est pour ça qu'il y a 200 enfants
répartis sur trois courses qu'ils vont
dire courir dimanche prochain quels sont
les difficultés de la course du 10 km
alors tu dis que cette montée au milieu
du parcours
c'est assez vallonné on va on commence
par une descente pour arriver jusqu'aux
étangs de la minière après on remonte
pour arriver vers le long de la ligne
droite de satori là en haut de la des
étangs et puis et puis un faux plat un
peu montant pour revenir jusqu'au
gymnase de des droits de l'homme de
Guyancourt mais alors un euro sera
reversé par coureur pour l'association
de l'air Sophie gueltier est-ce que vous
pouvez Galtier est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus je représente
cette association donc c'est qui lutte
en fait contre le cancer du poumon je
suis moi-même atteindre un cancer du
poumon mais ce qui m'a empêche pas de
faire du sport voilà parce que je fais
courage de ski et voilà pour
aller contrôler préjugés aussi ou quand
on parle cancer du poumon souvent on
parle on pense que que c'est uniquement
ce cancer du fumeur mais non moi je suis
l'exemple même de j'ai jamais fumé de ma
vie et donc j'ai un cancer du poumon
mais ce qui n'empêche pas de faire du
sport et notamment l'année dernière j'ai
fait la Guyancourt en effet bravo voilà
et vous serez bénévole du coup sur
l'opération cette année je suis bénévole
oui sur le sur l'association et
justement de l'isky également et vous
les rendre cette course éco-responsable
tout à fait pourquoi c'est un peu dans
l'air du temps aussi
dans l'air du temps mais on veut
diminuer les déchets on se dit qu'une
course il y a beaucoup de plastique il y
a beaucoup de de déchets faits par les
coureurs par l'organisation avec les
ravitaillements etc du coup on veut
essayer de diminuer tout ça diminuer
notre impact quoi augmenter notre
diminue la tempête écologique pardon et
donc travailler avec des des commerçants
locaux pour pour essayer de d'être de
décrocher cette cette norme de
labilisation des cours de cours c'est
quoi responsables
on peut encore s'inscrire c'est possible
vous pouvez vous inscrire soit sur le
site internet pardon de l'esqui
directement soit vous venez samedi entre
14h et 17h au gymnase des droits de
l'homme et vous êtes possibilité de vous
inscrire sur place au niveau de la météo
ils annoncent nuageux c'est à peu près
le temps qui fait sur la Guyancourt
chaque année ou ça
il a fait beau l'année dernière donc bon
oui froid mais non on espère que ça qui
fera pas la pluie surtout au démarrage
parce que c'est compliqué mais
normalement ils annoncent un temps à peu
près correct ça ajoute un peu de piment
peut-être la pluie oui un peu de fraise
surtout
Michael vous semble intéressant 10 km
c'est facile pour vous
80 km pour les courses un peu moins mais
les 10 km c'est un peu plus loin
à peu près à la même chose pour moi dans
les deux cas ce serait très bien merci à
vous deux d'être venu parler de cette
Guyancourt donc pour rappel la
Guyancourt c'est ce dimanche 26 mars à
Guyancourt on va maintenant passer aux
résultats sportif du week-end et on
commence par du football Michael dans le
championnat de National 2 Poissy n'a pu
faire mieux que match nul sur son
terrain contre la réserve de Caen le
score trois buts à zéro entre les deux
équipes au classement ce deuxième match
nul consécutif n'arrange pas les picia
kills et les joueurs zibinois se
retrouvent à la troisième place mais ils
sont menacés par Chambly qui est à deux
points derrière on continue de parler de
football on fait le point sur la
première division de district 6 matchs
étaient au programme dans ce championnat
où il y a fait match nul contre l'équipe
de des Mureaux Conflans s'impose
facilement sur le terrain de Valais 78
Bahi noisy gagne face à l'équipe 3 du FC
Mantois Le Chesnay domine Limay sur le
score de trois buts à zéro match
spectaculaire entre
U2 et voisins 4 à 3 pour les joueurs du
nord du département fin Marly-le-Roi
gagne contre Épône 1 à 0 au classement
où il est premier avec 32 points devant
baguinoisi et Marly-le-Roi un mode de
rugby à présent avec le championnat
de très bon match ce weekend de l'Union
rugby centre 78 le club né d'une fusion
entre
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le skyrugby c'est
imposé contre Lille Adam le score 46 à
19 une victoire qui fait du bien en
classement les joueurs zibinois se
retrouvent à la troisième place à un
petit point du deuxième banuche on
poursuit ses résultats sportifs avec du
basket nickel en National 3 rien ne va
plus pour trap qui descend lentement
dans les profondeurs de la division les
strappy se sont inclinés 68 à 61 sur le
parquet du Mans à Saint-Pavin pourtant
avant dernier du championnat les joueurs
50 chinois sont à la dixième place sur
14 avec 31 points engrangés depuis le
début de la saison prochain match pour
trap le samedi 1er avril à domicile
contre Rueil il faudrait éviter la
mauvaise blague faudrait éviter la
mauvaise blague effectivement en basket
féminin cette fois-ci une belle
performance pour le chêne et Versailles
les yvelinoises sont imposées 66 à 58
sur leur parquet face au quatrième du
classement une belle performance qui
leur permet de chiper cette quatrième
place à leurs adversaires du soir le
chien Versailles totalise 31 points
depuis le début de la saison avec 11
victoires et 9 défaites on continue de
parler de sport féminin mais en handball
cette fois-ci c'était chaud mais elles
ont réussi à gagner
Montigny-le-Bretonneux s'est imposé à
domicile contre 50 ans handball le score
25 à 24 cette victoire permet aux
ini-montaines d'être dans le top 5 de la
Nationale 2 prochain match pour
Montigny-le-Bretonneux à samedi soir
prochain dans la salle d'Hazebrouck et
bien bravo à elle après les terrains on
va prendre la direction des bassins
Michael le Giant open était organisé
pour la première fois ce dimanche à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye l'occasion pour le
public de voir des stars françaises
comme Charlotte bonnet ou encore Maxime
Grousset retour sur ce week-end qui a
réuni plusieurs milliers de spectateurs
avec Régine ralech
ce dimanche 19 mars l'ambiance était au
rendez-vous au Dôme de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pour la première
fois depuis 2019 l'Île-de-France a
accueilli un grand meeting de natation
le Giant open c'est un très grand
honneur parce que c'est la plus grande
compétition de natation en France on est
à quelques centaines de jours du début
des Jeux Olympiques et donc pour nous
qui sommes terre de vœux centre de
préparation des Jeux Olympiques c'est un
peu ce point de départ olympique donc on
est ravi évidemment d'accueillir le
monde de la natation à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye je suis fier de
pouvoir promouvoir cet événement c'est
le premier en la matière le Giant open
ici à Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est on
espère le premier d'une longue édition
parce que à l'époque on avait d'autres
formats de compétition internationaux
les tribunes étaient remplies en famille
ou entre amis les supporters sont venus
nombreux ils étaient 600 ce dimanche
vous voulez voir tous les nageurs que
j'aimais et comme je suis nager je
voulais peut-être essayer d'améliorer ma
technique en fonction de comment il nage
parce qu'on habite pas très loin de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'était l'occasion
de pouvoir voir des athlètes qu'on verra
peut-être pas aux JO ce nouveau format
de compétition a d'ailleurs été très
bien accueilli par les nageurs notamment
les deux têtes d'affiches Maxime
Grousset ce n'est au calédonien qui a
remporté le 100 mètres nage libre en
48,50 ou encore charlotte Bonnet
nouvelle record de woman sur le 100m
brasse une super ambiance là pour ma
finale tout le monde m'a super bien
encouragé je l'ai senti
aussi Saint-Germain donc très beau
complexe bien pour accueillir des des
meetings comme celui-ci et vraiment une
très très bonne ambiance beaucoup de
publics qui nous encouragent et qui sont
inférieurs nous au l'équipe de France
donc ça fait plaisir le Giant Open est
comme un avant-goût pour la ville de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye qui a été élu
centre de préparation pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris 204
on va maintenant parler de cyclisme sur
piste et notamment d'une piste de
licencié à Maul dans les Yvelines mais
qui courent pour le lao son nom Fanny
Cauchois on la mort pasienne va partir
dans quelques jours pour une étape de
coupe du monde à Milton et on est ravis
de l'avoir sur ce plateau bonsoir
bonsoir alors tout d'abord comment
est-ce que se déroule votre saison alors
c'est assez compliqué parce que avec les
JO ils ont décalé la saison cette année
mais c'est principalement quand même
toute l'année qu'on a des compétitions
alors vous courez depuis deux ans à peu
près pour pour le Laos pourquoi pourquoi
ce choix
de représenter mes origines pour pouvoir
mettre en avant ce pays devant la scène
et du coup c'était pas trop compliqué
enfin d'aller avec le Laos vous êtes
vous êtes vous aurez pu aller vers
l'équipe de France par exemple
ça a été assez compliqué les démarches
surtout qu'on les a faites pendant le
covid et en Asie le covid c'était autre
chose l'équipe de France ne m'a jamais
contacté je n'ai jamais été en relation
avec eux et du coup être pistard de pour
l'équipe du Laos ça représente quoi pour
vous enfin ça se passe comment
concrètement vous vous entraînez en
France mais vous faites partie de
l'équipe au Laos oui c'est ça ce n'est
pas du tout un sport qui est démocratisé
là-bas ils font du cyclisme sur route et
du VTT mais ils ne connaissent pas la
piste donc ce n'est pas facile mais j'ai
à coeur de représenter ce pays et de
pouvoir démocratiser ce sport aussi
là-bas est-ce que vous avez des fans
là-bas au Laos
vous avez des messages des fois il vous
envoie des messages vous soutiennent sur
Facebook sur les réseaux sociaux tout il
me soutiennent énormément pendant les
compétitions alors vous entraîner
régulièrement sur cette piste du
vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
parce que vous habitez Maurepas donc
c'est pas très très loin est-ce que vous
imaginez être en 2024 avec le Laos aux
Jeux olympiques de 2024 à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
sachant qu'il est depuis un mois les
qualifications ont commencé donc oui je
m'y vois je m'y entraîne j'ai fait les
derniers championnats du monde là-bas
donc bien sûr c'est l'objectif
prochainement de cette fameuse Coupe du
Monde au Canada qu'est-ce qui vous reste
à faire j'ai envie de dire pour pour
être qualifié pour pour faire ces Jeux
Olympiques et bien c'est un système de
ranking sur plusieurs compétitions et il
faut être du coup dans les 22 premières
pour pouvoir participer ça commence du
coup dès maintenant la préparation
est-ce qu'on intensifie dès à présent ou
il y a encore un petit peu de temps pour
arriver aux Jeux Olympiques c'est une
préparation sur plusieurs mois on a des
objectifs donc par exemple moi le mois
prochain je vais au Canada pour la Coupe
du monde après j'aurai un petit temps
mort mais j'aurais les championnats
d'Asie au mois de juin par contre les
championnats d'Europe ou d'Océanie ou
d'Afrique ont déjà eu lieu donc ça
dépend des continents des compétitions
de des du choix des compétitions qu'on
fait et vous avez déjà un objectif de
résultat dès à présent pour les jeux
pour les jeux pour le moment l'objectif
ça sera la qualification après une fois
qualifié
on avisera de l'objectif final alors je
rappelle que vous avez 22 ans il vous
reste du temps donc ça sera 2024 ou
peut-être 2028 à Los Angeles
effectivement à plus long terme
l'objectif ça serait Los Angeles 2028 et
ce n'est pas trop dur d'être la seule
représentante de l'équipe féminine du
Laos
ce mentalement ou c'est pas trop c'est
pas trop compliqué non c'est pas
compliqué au contraire même je sais que
je me qualifie pour moi-même et moi-même
je prépare mes objectifs donc non je
dirais même que c'est un honneur même si
j'aimerais bien pourquoi pas
démocratiser donc ce sport là bas et que
il y est plus tard des filles qui en
font les inspirer pourquoi pas vous avez
envie
d'engendrer une dynamique oui oui
beaucoup alors je sais qu'il y a pas de
Vélodrome là-bas mais au moins du
cyclisme est sur route que les femmes
puissent en faire à plus haut niveau et
justement on vous appelle là-bas pour
donner des cours des formations des
conseils pas encore parce que de toute
façon en étant athlète de niveau et en
plus à côté je fais mes études j'ai pas
énormément de temps mais peut-être
qu'après ma carrière je me déplacerai
là-bas pour pour parler de mon parcours
et pouvoir inspirer des femmes lescours
chercher des sponsors aussi on sait que
c'est quand même assez coû teux tous ces
déplacements est-ce que vous recherchez
des sponsors oui bien sûr c'est une
préparation olympique c'est un certain
coût alors j'ai le Laos qui m'aide mais
c'est un pays qui n'est pas très riche
et c'est vrai que je suis preneuse pour
les partenariats si vous voulez me
contacter sur les réseaux sociaux il y a
aucun problème
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous souder du
coup pour ces prochains mois et bien de
pouvoir me qualifier pour léger à Paris
2024 et qu'on s'y retrouve et bien merci
beaucoup à vous Fanny Cauchois homme
d'avoir répondu à nos questions on vous
souhaite bon courage pour la suite de
votre carrière et on continuera de la
suivre bien évidemment sur TV 78 à moins
de 500 jours des Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 l'entreprise Cisco l'un des
partenaires officiels des JO a organisé
génération champion une après-midi où
les jeunes yvelinois ont pu découvrir
les sports olympiques et paralympiques
l'événement a fait étape ce samedi 18
mars au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le reportage
de Grégory canalet et Mélanie poquet ils
ne seront pas athlètes olympiques en
2024 mais en seront très certainement
spectateurs 180 années-luminois ont pu
profiter de générations une après-midi
de sport organisée par Cisco l'un des
partenaires des JO au Vélodrome national
de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines il y a
beaucoup d'activités
on s'amuse on profite et on donne tout
le meilleur de nous-même sachant qu'il y
a des récompenses à la fin j'ai préféré
le tir à l'arc parce que c'est vrai
c'est très dur on peut s'initier à
beaucoup d'activités on peut découvrir
des nouveaux sports on a pu voir des
athlètes de haut niveau que parce que
aux JO et très bien ces athlètes de haut
niveau les champions du monde de 110
mètres et en 2005 et Vincent Luis
triathlète multiple champion du monde et
médaillé de bronze en relais mixte lors
des dernières Olympiades la génération
avait grandir et on espère que grâce à
cet événement il deveniendront des
grandes des grandes personnes et du coup
bah il faut il faut aller à des endroits
qui font la promotion de ce genre
d'événement personnellement voilà c'est
agrandir mon sport moi le talon
transmettre aux jeunes cette passion du
sport et cette passion d'être dehors et
on a la chance pour pour les athlètes
français comme moi d'avoir les jeux à la
maison c'est des choses qui arrivent
très très peu dans une carrière ce sera
mes quatrième jeu moi et voilà
j'aimerais bien que ça se finisse
vraiment en apothéose avec un bon
résultat l'événement a fait étape samedi
18 mars il était destiné aux enfants de
8 à 16 ans participent à des activités
olympiques et paralympiques nous disons
pas forcément l'habitude de participer
il y a du tennis fauteuil voilà c'est
vraiment promotion aussi du handisport
et puis voilà la visite aussi de de ce
site futur site olympique le Stadium BMX
aussi des initiations et des challenges
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines étaient l'une
des quatre étapes de l'événement
prochain rendez-vous Nice le 1er avril
[Musique]
Fanny qu'est-ce que ça vous fait de voir
cette génération
2024 ici au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et en plus je pense que le cyclisme
surpisse c'est pas très connu à
l'extérieur du 78 quand on connaît pas
forcément le vélo de route nationale
donc je trouve ça vraiment génial
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
merci Michel et le midro pour toutes ces
informations sur les résultats sportifs
on vous retrouve la semaine prochaine du
coup comme d'habitude comme toujours
vous avez déjà de quoi est-ce que vous
allez nous parler ou pas encore
l'actualité
va me guider l'actualité sportive à me
guider la semaine prochaine donc restez
bien avec nous la semaine prochaine
avant de se quitter on va jeter un
dernier coup d'œil à la météo de demain
demain matin pour ce premier jour de
printemps le ciel devrait être dégagé
sur la partie sud-est du département
dans le nord-ouest les nuages resteront
bien présents au niveau des températures
il fera 9 degrés à Houdan Rambouillet et
Versailles et 10 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'après-midi le
soleil devrait être au rendez-vous sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines avec de belles
éclaircies côté température il fera 14
degrés en moyenne sur l'ensemble du
département et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]